foreign
[Music]
[Music]
Alex Rodriguez is one proud papa she's a
natural what can I say the former MLB
star's daughter Natasha sang the
national anthem at a Miami Heat game and
A-Rod was totally gleaming as he watched
his 17 year old belt the Star-Spangled
Banner
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
he shared a video of the moment to
Instagram writing a sweet message for
his little girl wow I will never forget
last night Tashi I am so proud you did
such an amazing job you have to be
passionate about what you're putting on
that stage
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah the girls got some pipes but it's
not the first time she showed off her
talent to a big crowd
last month Natasha wowed at a Miami
Marlins baseball game
foreign
but hey she's not only gifted in the
Arts but academics too so X we're
divided by six and it equals five
so x equals five and it makes sense
because six times two and three times
two is six and five times
two equals ten
okay our children uh focus on all the
right things at home Alex has always
been clear about how he approaches the
dad role I want to be a great father and
a present father and someone who
promotes self-esteem for their for their
daughters but he's always on hand to
give them a quick lesson or two in
business one of my favorite times of the
day is when I drive my daughters to
school I always try to teach him one
business lesson and of course they're
like Oh Daddy no more business but you
know what they're learning and uh I
can't say they're enjoying it but they
are learning the former athlete recently
sat down for a wide-ranging interview
with CNN's Chris Wallace he shared how
his definition of success has changed
since his steroid scandal in 2014. post
suspension I look at more the team
building being a great father being a
son being a friend
High character loyalty all those things
a-rod's clearly got the dad game on lock
but what about Sunday adding husband to
the resume I think I'm gonna make a
wonderful partner or husband and father
post suspension because the Lessons
Learned of my biggest mistakes for now
we love seeing this proud papa and his
daughters shine
[Music]
foreign